hey guys Mary here showing off gamespot
presents the mix at GDC 2016 I'm here
with Andy from pocket watch game hi hi
and you're gonna show me tooth and tail
although I'm actually seeing this you
have seen this game you guys changed the
name uh-huh yeah that's right so this
game is actually been in development I
saw this at PAX East last year baby
packs Western I'm yeah so tell me about
tooth and tails so anyone who's never
seen it before to think you know it's
it's this is the game that I wanted to
play in college it's this it's a split
screen realtime strategy game you can
also play online but one of the things
about realtime strategy games is they're
so intimidating to get online and play
no one wants to do it so we wanted to
make a game that is super accessible but
just as deep as all of the other
realtime strategy games out there so you
can play this game on a controller and
we're gonna be super interests we are
yeah so so like we can basically fight
for King at the dorm room right queen of
the dorm room that's right and you can
tell yeah so let's get into it and
you'll have to give me no I did play
this but it's been a couple it's been a
couple years it has changed a lot our
last couple of years it'd be a nice
overview sure so it's a real-time
strategy game in the game world you what
here's the here's that the conceit of
the world where the animals and we ran
in revolution and we're fighting over
who is going to be able to eat and who
is going to have to be dinner okay so
you're gonna be a nice I'll put a nice
cream sauce on you came out wrong sorry
that's awful
yeah so anyways this is to pursue until
we're playing as the animals and we are
going to fight over who's going to be
eating it okay so we're gonna go to vs.
and split-screen and these the maps are
all random via one I'm so sorry the maps
the maps are all randomized so if you
hit start here okay and we will we're
ready out so go up and ready up you can
actually select what is what units are
in your army so you can really customize
things and play to your own style so if
you're the type of person who just wants
to turtle up you can totally do that in
this game for now why don't you just
stick with with the units that it gave
you and go up and click on to battle
yeah
standard four yeah exactly there's all
sorts of different yeah - snake - wolf -
yeah so the Tier one units are kind of
your cannon fodder that peep and those
are the ones you'll build at the
beginning of the game and then the tier
twos start to become a little more of a
utility unit so you have this ferret
artillery you have a chameleon that can
stealth until he gets close to things
and they on stilts and the attacks okay
Falcons are your air units and then you
have your Tier three units which are
like your boss units they're super
expensive they don't come out until the
end of the game you have like a honey
badger that has a minigun okay you have
a boar a wild boar that has a
flamethrower you have a Fox sniper an
owl that pukes up Mouse paratroopers and
a wolf that can howl and he buffs his
entire army and then you have your
defensive units over here so you have
like land mines and and machine-gun
turrets and balloon snipers and
artillery cannons and things like that
so I will choose that and we'll we'll go
about
you know I'm gonna pick the skunk
because the skunk bottles his own farts
throw something okay well we'll try a
different one so you can see different
uh perfect different character yeah in
fact I'll do the mole as well mall the
malls are reference to our last game
which was Monaco if you played Monaco
that was the previous game before this
so this is split screen and it's super
simple to play you can even see the
controller help up there so the first
thing you probably want to do is go
build a farm so go stand on one of those
empty farm plots okay move up a little
bit I'm not right there and press a you
can also play this with a mouse and
keyboard as well and it's just as easy
to play so while that's building we
might want you might want to go off on
scout and figure out where I am all
right so these are my workers right now
those are your resource exactly they're
they're getting they're growing for you
and that's me so I'm coming over here to
check out what the heck you're scoping
out my area now how would you be able to
tell maybe what I'm going to be building
so a lot of this game is about hiding
your hands so it's kind of like poker
where it's like you kind of have to read
what the other person is doing by their
behavior okay right because they can
have a hidden hand so you aren't gonna
know exactly what I'm building until the
units come out so there's a lot of this
like bluffing and trying to read your
opponent you can hold down the X button
also to burl home anytime okay you're
already there so exactly and what else
what I'd be scouting besides you so you
so one of the interesting things about
having random maps in real time strategy
games is it means that you have to
actually explore you've you've you've
never seen this particular map before so
you want to figure out where the
backdoors are and like where you're
gonna have to set up your defenses so
you might want to be careful because I'm
about to start building some units and
I'm gonna come at a keys okay so burrow
home I'll hold that hold X button and
then go build a Warren inne anywhere in
this end the empty space oh hey
because you can actually burrow to any
of your windmills you
that's ready all right so I wanted so go
out to the empty area that's not on a
farm and press a so that's gonna build
what's called a Warren and the Warren's
will produce units for you autonomously
so you don't have to one of the things
that's cool about this game is all of
your army control and unit control
happens just by pulling the trigger okay
so for instance I have I have a couple
of toads here that these guys are
suicide bombers they'll come in and blow
up in your units and I can pull they do
that automatically or you can will you
can micro them a little bit so I can
pull the right trigger if I'm holding
the trigger it's it's a move command if
I release it it's an attack move command
so they'll actually attack whatever's
near then once I release it okay and I
can also control just a single type of
unit with my left trigger so if I want
to like do a flanking attack or
something like that I can do that so
you're coming in with your lizards my
toads are gonna oh you already might old
blue some of them up oh no now you're
coming in to get into my economy and I'm
in trouble so I'm gonna actually spend
some some food on these moles the moles
will come in the pigs will shoot back we
sure did yeah cannon yeah how do I build
like a rake like a higher level so use
your right analog stick to cycle over
the different units exactly and so and
any time if you feel like you don't have
enough food you can always stand over
that warna hit B to sell it so the games
last typically around 10 minutes or so
it's a nice length of time a match we we
like to say they were kind of hard
stoning Starcraft okay you know because
it's like hearthstone took Magic the
Gathering which was a pretty complicated
game and and you know without taking the
the complexity out of it kind of make it
cent made it simpler to play I think
you're gonna get me I'm running out of
units well so they will actually
automatically respawn you'll see at the
bottom of the screen don't respawn in
there so you've yeah you do something
good yeah I did start a new one over
here right and you can get more farms in
order to get more food all right so I
can have more currency to be making more
exactly exactly yeah yeah and you can
also set up some defenses do you see you
have a machine-gun turret there yeah I'm
the farthest right one try selling one
of your warrants and then so walk stand
over it hit B and then build go to the
front of your base and hit in and select
the machine gun turret and hit a all the
way on the right okay so there you go so
that's a machine gun turret that's how
you build up your defenses and yeah I
think I'm gonna come in here and see if
I can take you out I can come up here on
the high ground and let my ferrets
actually rain death down upon you from
from up on high oh no you have a
different it's interesting to see how
the unit's intermix with each other but
the animations are really beautiful
thank you so it's like interesting
visually alright let's see if I can oh
oh you're getting in there alright you
get into my face I'm throwing you're
doing great heaps and heaps o units at
you hoping that it'll work out alright I
think you're I think I'm coming for you
here oh god hold on I could probably
have fun make a whole bunch of malls and
attack the base though kill that machine
gun turret
looking for people those lizards keep
taking me out come on Moss let's go you
have so many moles so the moles are
special in that they you can build them
out in the field they don't they don't
need a warrant to produce so it's kind
of like they're like summon units so I'm
bringing my malls in and I think you're
gonna big trouble yeah I think this
might be it for me the the the
soundtrack is all by Austin Larry who's
probably best known for doing the
journey soundtrack he also did the
Assassin's Creed syndicate soundtrack
recently so he's he he's a his he does
such interesting work so we're we're
doing we're doing all this based on like
turn-of-the-century like World War one
era Russian Commodore music uh-huh
it's got a really good theme to it and
you guys haven't deviated from that at
all give it a really good atmosphere
mm-hmm
now is there any kind of story campaign
is you want to know if you want to try
it out
let's give it a shot I'm gonna actually
surrender and I'll hand this over to you
and you can explore oh cool - yeah
showing you can you can actually watch
the replay of the entire match so I can
actually watch what it was that you were
up to and I can even go into - double
speed and and I speed this up so if your
enemy beat you you can see what it is
they were up to kind of investigate them
a little bit more yeah it looks like
we're just about at a time all right
thank you so much for showing me two
thin tale that game looks amazing and
when can we expect to go get that so
this game's gonna be out later this year
we don't have it a specific date on it
but the plan is for later this year
later this year you guys can check out
tooth and tail thank you
you